das ist wirklich der hammer fast
zeitgleich haben zwei forschungsteams
aus deutschland und norwegen ein akku
auf siliziumbasis gebaut der im
vergleich zur gewöhnlichen lithium ionen
technik weit mehr kann
der neuartige akku hast deutschland
beispielsweise weiß die zehnfache
lagerkapazität auf und auch sein
ladevorgang dauert nur wenige minuten
rott klicks um science-fiction hier gibt
es täglich faszinierendes heinz videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's vielen dank für
euren themenvorschlag aufseher whatsapp
community herzlich willkommen wer kennt
es nicht nur rauch 3% akku und das
natürlich immer in ungünstigen
situationen beispielsweise dann wenn man
einen wichtigen anruf machen muss oder
aber noch eine dringende nachricht
verschicken will der traum von allen
handynutzer rinnen und nutzern eine
lange akkulaufzeit kombiniert mit einer
kurzen ladezeiten
ähnlich ergeht es wohl allen nutzern von
elektroautos ich kann ein lied davon
singen und diese träume könnten
vielleicht bald wirklichkeit werden eine
erfindung aus deutschland macht jetzt
hoffnung darauf ein forschungsteam aus
kiel hat einen akku auf der basis von
silizium gebaut und das ergebnis ist
vielversprechend bisher setzt man ja in
der batterietechnik auf graphit anoden
doch bei diesem neuartigen akku wurde
als anoden material silizium verbaut und
es ist tatsächlich ideal dafür geeignet
denn es speichert deutlich mehr energie
als graphit 500 ladung und entladung hat
das forschungsteam bereits vorgenommen
und gezeigt dass der aufladevorgang
gerade einmal zwölf minuten dauert ein
entsprechende akkus der auf der lithium
ionen technik basiert würde fünf stunden
brauchen silizium ist in der erdhöhle
nach sauerstoff das zweit häufigste
element es ist also breit verfügbar und
hat äußerst günstige
materialeigenschaften beispielsweise ist
es flammen hemd was einen weiteren
pluspunkt in der batterietechnik
darstellt das größte problem dagegen
bestand für das forschungsteam aus der
mechanischen instabilität des siliziums
denn beim laden dehnt es sich achtung um
400 prozent aus also es wird vier mal so
groß und kann so schnell zerbrechen
das alles basiert auf seiner hohen
energiedichte so dass besonders viele
die union aufgenommen werden
doch wie genau hat das forschungsteam
diese herausforderung gelöst sie
brachten das silizium in die
mikrostruktur eines dünnen rates so war
es flexibel und konnten die starke
ausdehnung gut überstehen schon länger
haben wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler im bereich der
elektromobilität silizium als großen
hoffnungsträger identifiziert denn na
klar elektroautos hätten so eine viel
viel viel höhere reichweite aber auch
das problem mit den handy akkus könnte
so bald der vergangenheit angehören und
auch andere batteriebetriebene produkte
könnten ja deutlich optimiert werden
beispielsweise hörgeräte die so weiter
verkleinert werden könnten ja und nun
sind die wissenschaftlerinnen
wissenschaftler aus kiel daran auch die
kathode weiter zu optimieren
die idee ist es sie aus schwefel zu
bauen und so die speicherkapazität des
akkus noch weiter zu maximieren das
alles wäre ein absolut riesiger
fortschritt und fast zu schön um wahr zu
sein wenn diese idee ist nicht nur im
sinne der forscherinnen forscher und der
nutzerinnen und nutzer sondern auch im
sinne der umwelt um dann aber wirklich
auch einen durchbruch in der
akkutechnologie darzustellen müsste dann
jedoch auch der sprung vom
forschungslabor in die industrielle
fertigung gelingen holt fast zeitgleich
zu dem forschungsteam aus kiel haben
auch wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler aus norwegen an diesem
konzept getüftelt hier ist das projekt
schon so weit fortgeschritten dass die
technologien nun patentiert werden soll
und industrielle tests anstehen auch bei
der norwegischen arbeit ging es darum
silizium endlich in größeren mengen als
anoden material verbauen zu können und
das trotz seiner enormen ausdehnung beim
ladevorgang die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler haben das durch die
kombination von graphit und silizium
geschafft so wurde die maximierung des
silizium anteils erreicht und durch den
grafit anteils zugleich eine radikale
ausdehnung verhindert auch dieses
projekt würde beispielsweise die elektro
mobilität revolutionieren zukünftige
elektroautos könnten rund 1000 kilometer
zurücklegen mit nur einer auflage und
auch smartphones könnten tage lang
laufen doch wissen davon dann im alltag
tatsächlich profitieren werden wir uns
bestimmt noch einige jahre gedulden
ich kriege echt ein bisschen gänsehaut
wenn ich da an die zukunft mit solchen
akkus denke und gänsehaut die gibt es
auch bei dieser video premiere auf dem
englischen blick zum kanal smaller
senioren of rice wird eines computers
das gibt es hier einfach draufklicken
ich freue mich auf euch auf dem
englischen kanal zu tun
stay tuned